foreign
well hello there you are watching The
Press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with the daily
mirrors associate editor Kevin McGuire
and the telegraphs deputy comment editor
Annabelle Denham welcome to both of you
great to see you so let's take a look at
the front pages shall we let's start
with the eye leading with fears that the
government's Bill aimed at ending the
flow of small boats crossing the channel
could jeopardize the landmark winter
agreement made with the EU last week
that story is also the lead for the
guardian sunac facing a clash with the
European Union it says Daily Mail
examining the possibility of BBC
presenter Gary lineker losing his job
over remarks he made about the new
Asylum plan but the mirror quotes lilica
are saying he will never be silenced
the telegraph reports that at the height
of the pandemic the former Health
secretary Matt Hancock was advised to
tone down his claims that the covid
virus originated in a Chinese lab of
Affairs it could spoil British relations
with Beijing
the Metro has word of the christening of
Harry and Megan's daughter Princess
lilibet and the fact she'll somewhat
unexpectedly be using that title The
Times reporting on the Revolutionary new
weight loss drug for the NHS which could
lead to a cut in a country's benefits
bill the financial times understands
that the government plans to tackle
shortages in the labor market by
loosening rules surrounding foreign
workers in the construction sector and
the Daily Star has the story of a
profane parrot
well a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us or I'll guests more
specifically so let's head straight to
Kevin McGuire and Annabelle Devin
welcome to both of you
um so the repercussions then of the
Asylum Bill the guardian then Kevin
sunac facing a clash with European Union
what's happening the EU beginning to
react to it are they
yeah maybe the legal migration bill as
its course should be called the illegal
illegal migration bill because the Clash
here is with the European Union the home
Affairs commissioner Eva Johansson is
that how I pronounce her name as I said
she spoke to swella Brahman the Home
Secretary on Tuesday and said they
thought it was uh unlawful but brought
them and pushed back said not but we now
know that she thinks the odds are that
it will fall far of the European
Convention of human rights which for all
the angry swivelied extremists uh is not
the same as the European court of
justice or anything to do with the
European Union
uh so it's it's unfortunate from the
prime minister in the UK at the very
least when he seemed to be resetting
relations with the European Union
through the uh the Windsor framework to
resolve problems around the the brexit
um
uh relationship in Northern Ireland the
protocol that this is this has come
along and I think this this bill as the
guardian Point uh points out on his
front page yeah some people just think
it's cynical really to get the to get
the issue up in politics and for the
election rather than actually resolving
the the problem of uh of Boat Crossings
refugees Asylum and migration yes and
the Guardian saying the Home Secretary
disagreed with the commissioner and
asked her to read the detail of the bill
once it was published that's a a source
close to Brotherman speaking to the
guardian all of this of course the head
of a summit between President macro and
Rishi sunak on Friday but the eye going
in a sense slightly further as well soon
like small boats Bill risks brexit peace
with Europe all that good work done with
us you live on the lion
um undone um you know within within a
few days it seems Annabelle
well it certainly does I mean I think
that we she said I probably expected
that taking a harder line approach to
tackling the migrant crisis would risk
slightly damaging relations with Europe
which of course as you say have thawed
significantly since the announcement of
the Windsor framework he and Emmanuel
macron are meeting for a reasonably
important Summit in Paris and it'll be
interesting to see the body language
um there and how that that meeting goes
but I think you know British student
made this one of his um five pillars
this is one of the promises that he's
trying to make to the British public in
the run-up to the next general election
he will know that this won't have been
uh easy I suspect there's a high chance
that the Stalls before it makes any
progress at all even though it makes it
through the commons will it make it
through the Lords and even make it
through the Lords will it make it uh
through the courts um you know this
issue of Asylum has been a guardian not
and Homestead secretaries have tied
themselves in it for years you know who
doesn't want to offer Asylum to those
who fear persecution in their homelands
who are fleeing for Morton countries
um it's also I think difficult to object
to anyone wanting to improve their lives
and the lives of their families by
coming here as economic migrants but the
increase in the number of people coming
here from a few hundred in 2018 to tens
of thousands last year is deeply
troubling and an issue that many voters
care about deeply so it's not altogether
surprising that sunaka is looking to
address this and I think it's quite
interesting that the labor party are not
really objecting to this on
compassionate grounds but rather
baffling with the conservatives over who
has a better idea of how to stop the
boats yes and certainly you've got the
impression that uh Rishi sunak and the
conservatives have done focus groups on
this the way he was speaking at premises
questions you know we're speaking for
the people of Britain etc etc but the
eye picking up on that Summit on Friday
with Emmanuel macro suggesting he will
demand annual multi-million pound
payments to prevent people illegally
crossing the channel the treasury
signaling the paper says it will
increase cash for policing beaches the
times also reporting that macron will
demand annual UK payments to tackle the
small boats crisis it's going to cost us
a lot of money this cooperation with
Europe isn't it Kevin
yeah well it well it is and of course
we're we're no longer part of the the
Dublin convention whereby people could
be sent back to the country from which
they'd arrived and in the European Union
that doesn't exist anymore uh and yes it
will it will cost money but there's no
easy solution to to this problem there
is a problem people coming over on on
boats they're risking they're risking
their lives they arrive unlawfully but
there are no safe and legal routes often
uh for them to apply and so many uh the
majority of people once they get here
they are allowed to stay because they
have legitimate claims
the government wants to use the channel
as a mode to stop them making those
claims in the first place that's that's
it and you can you can do that by
stopping the stopping the sailings uh
and then once they arrive if you do
reject them then you need agreements to
to send them elsewhere Rwanda was never
really more than something to wave
around because it would never it would
never take the numbers but it's also
quite interesting Anna that the whole
Focus from the government appears to be
on both which is 45 000 last year the
home secretaries saying projections this
year it could be 80 000 unless they're
stopped net migration in the UK last
year was 504 000 uh a record but the
government almost wants nobody to see
that and question it as it uh focuses
almost entirely on the on the boats as
an issue because it can see the
Electoral Advantage from doing that and
uh hopefully embarrassing about
embarrassing labor you're spotting a
diversionary tactic there are you Kevin
but in the meanwhile it is yeah we'll go
to the Daily Mail uh it's about linear
it was again last night for them you
know look at the banner headlines along
the top their staff are boiling with
anger at the stars disdain for rules
they obey he fails to apologize for the
Nazi slur B crisis talks is insiders say
he's passed a Tipping Point should he as
a sports presenter be allowed to speak
out that's been the question today
yes and I think Gary lineker has gone to
some lengths to try and make this a free
speech uh issue
um of course you know for viewers who
perhaps haven't been watching the news
over the last 24 hours uh this is uh
Gary lineker
um comparing the illegal migrant Bill to
uh 1930s Germany and the language used
within that bill
um to 1930s Germany it's caused a huge
amount of outrage um not least that it
downplays the persecution of uh Jewish
people under Hitler but also and that's
what this story is really focusing on is
that it undermines the interpartiality
of the BBC we know that when the new BBC
director General Tim Davey came in uh he
launched a crusade on BBC impartiality
and I think you know he's now under a
lot of pressure to sack Gary lineker to
take a hard uh tough approach
um to these tweets
um and now Gary lineker has actually
doubled down which is only going to
further intensify that pressure and at
the moment we're being told that the BBC
is going to have a Frank uh conversation
with the um match of the day uh
presenter
um to my mind these comments weren't uh
reasonable and I suspect that they might
go against the BBC's social media
guidelines which would insist on
impartiality for uh reporters but also
for presenters even if they are tweeting
in their own name but let's not forget
that guy lineker is famous because of
the BBC he has millions of followers on
Twitter because of the role that the BBC
has given him which would in large part
be paid for by levy on the British
population the license fee so you can
see why so many BBC employees and The
Wider public are incensed by this and I
think Tim Davis to say is in a very
difficult position and it will be
interesting to see what what decision is
made in the coming days yes your paper
also um kicking off with this as well
Kevin lineker I will never be silenced
um the problem for the BBC and what ties
their hands a bit is this question of
impartiality is very critical with a
Tory government in power you know the
likes of Nadine Doris it's been an
undermining effect of the BBC
um and the part they play in in news and
so on so this this is this has become
very important for them
yeah no
is far more sympathetic to uh Gary
lineker than the the male which seems to
be salivating and hoping he is his
psyched but you're quite quite right it
is very difficult for for the BBC and
Tim Dave if he's laying down the law and
it is being defied now of course in
litica's defense it would be that he is
in sport he's not in news or current
affairs so you could argue that's rather
rather different but he's been
criticized once before uh over as a
challenging trust when she was foreign
secretary and she said uh the Champions
League final should be we shouldn't be
in Russia at the end it was in Paris uh
disaster for Liverpool fans who were
treated upon him unless it was it was in
past rather than Russia and he said well
there's a Tory party going to give the
uh the Russian donations back to no it's
very very difficult the Tory party
always says the BBC is a hotbed of
lefties and liberals and overlooking the
fact David Cameron and Boris Johnson
both got their uh press secretaries from
from the BB you see a lot of people from
the BBC go and work for the Tories in in
power but it but it is difficult now
litica himself when he was talking about
the 1930s Germany he wasn't talking
about concentration camps he's talking
about the dehumanization of people and
he was actually echoing a holocaust
Survivor who confronted the Home
Secretary herself back in January and
made that very very point but there's no
there's no doubt once you raise the
Specter of um of Hitler and the Nazis
any uh any controversy you know goes to
warp speed immediately
just on the you know Asylum Asylum story
itself many people say why not put them
to work while they're here we've got a
shortage of workers and sort of
connected to that but different is the
ft's front page
um that ministers are planning to tackle
chronic shortages in the labor market
but opening the door to more foreign
workers starting with looser rules for
the construction sector would you
welcome this because certainly sectors
have been calling for this have they not
Annabelle
yes that's right so as you say this is
the news that the government wants to
tackle these labor market shortages
which have been experiencing really
since the economy reopened after uh
lockdown
um and they're going to do this by
loosening rules for foreign workers
particularly in the construction Center
a construction sector but really looking
at those areas where the shortages are
uh chronic and and most acute of course
at the same time ministers are looking
to tackle inactivity but they've yet to
come up with anything resembling a
workable solution some of the ideas
floated included job coaches being
posted at GP surgeries or no income tax
for the over 50s the latter of which
elicited reasonable outcry that it was
exacerbating in a ginter-generational uh
inequality but of course what we have
here is in the very same week that
Richie sunac is announcing his intention
to clamp down on illegal immigration
um ministers are now contemplating
targeted immigration to plug those
shortages as for the shortage occupation
list I'm I'm quite skeptical about this
um you know this allows this will allow
employers to bring in staff on a lower
salary threshold and with lower Visa
fees
um that when we started uh experiencing
those shortages after covid
um jobs like artists were on there when
chefs weren't even though we had a
shortage of I think around 30 000 chefs
at the time and I think this really
underscores that businesses require a
variety of workers with a range of
skills and salary expectations and those
devices and the people from the better
place than Whitehall to decide what they
need